I can't believe it I'm about to say next
but it is true
Jane recently threw some shade at me all
that's I did that's true I came across
an interview you gave let's check it out
who has shocked to you as far as being
the most aggressive like is there
someone who maybe came on Kelly Clarkson
was just completely off the charts she
was she's ordering everybody around you
ordering me around and she was kind of
cheating and this was for Red Nose Day
so we didn't have standards and practice
come down so she was just like you know
like grabbing the the bouncy ball out of
people's hands and saying I'm gonna do
that again so and we allowed it we
allowed it because it was fun and it was
good TV my family only knows and friends
but I'm actually quite annoyed well and
anyone that saw me on Hollywood game
night either sure but I'm I'm actually a
lot when I play games a lot but I didn't
think I cheated I didn't know here's the
thing this is true you don't know
whispering the right answer into your
partner's I know I thought it was a team
effort from our group and then the one
person to chat with no brother because
you knew it was wrong I didn't want the
other team to hear me okay well that
makes sense yeah no because literally
I'm hardcore on roles yours no kidding
yeah
no nope I'm on it you gotta bring out
flags like on the play yeah we should
have you see this is Red Nose Day so we
let people get away with this stuff but
we have a standards of practice
don't let us cheat yeah okay do you
don't see you did not on a case you know
I want you to be hard okay oh yeah all
right okay well I got coach I was in
sports I can I can handle gay I'm gonna
wear a whistle and I go all Sue
Sylvester on yeah I love it I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this